they fly down he still won't take a fee
and he killed it all day long him and
Kawhi were vibing I have some great
pictures I could share with you about it
and I was like how can I say thank you
to this guy like he just wanted a hotel
room and a first class flight for him
and this girl to come hang out with us
for the day
and
I said yo your favorite Jordans or
threes right he's like yeah I said I'm
gonna do something for you so that's how
these came out
um and you see the VL on the side for
Victory lap well I actually have a
Victory lap tattoo right here that's how
much I love nip just as a friend you can
see at the bottom of the VL but these
are really really special there's
probably 10.
[Music]